okay bye scuse me can I get by tag it
through here I supposed to get by you
ah come on okay
don't be dick get out of here I wrapped
up my arms just cuz I hate you so much
ignore what I'm doing ignore what I'm
doing now I well I mean sit we're you
know you saying I'm done with you no
okay I got what I needed
oh please just let me continue please
just let me continue I just wanna move
forward nice splits for an old man I
swear this is harder than Dead Souls
would be this is way harder oh I just
walked right by him and he fell over
good good he's kind of a deuce like that
oh happy wheels is supposed to be a
happy fun game why is it an angry girl
game
come on move forward cuz I'm playin
these damn Dark Souls levels let me over
your face dick get out of here yeah okay
anymore get out here you kill yourself
you can kill you some God come on get
out of here I am exceptionally crumpled
right now and I don't much care
oh now I got a spear on the end of my
stupid goddamn bike you get impaled you
produce I do you boosts you may have
noticed that this particular happy will
sigh like this filled with a stupid Dark
Souls levels that's because it won't let
me freedom but if I could just get by
the first few god damn it you see this
is why I can't play Dark Souls because
it doesn't do well for me does it do
well for me just love me through the
gate just let me through the game you
will be just fine you fall over like a
douche if
I'm unbelievably angry it cannot be this
hard I've gotten through many a level
like this before but this particular all
your friends with my new spear I just
obtained you get speared you deck you
get out of here you [ __ ] and a half oh
my balls but I don't care how your balls
get out of my way you dick bag douche
mother humper piece of ass [ __ ] and
balls ramming through the faces of
10,000 and stupid mother humping get
your spear out of there you're dead you
don't even matter anymore you're dead
you're dead son you got your dad your
gas you all can imagine how I'd be
actually playing Dark Souls this is why
I don't do it thanks it's very why do I
have a tail now why do I suddenly have a
tail no I said why am I doing this
splits come on come on there we go get
out get more dead than you already were
just get the most dead you could
possibly be and get out of my way let's
do this let go no you don't own oh you
don't
oh yeah fall the downstairs [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah no no no no no no no no
no or you got two axes that's really
cool how about you
brick brick brick great somebody must
add that markiplier is losing his mind
but that's impossible
cuz I am as smart and as dedicated as I
ever was to my own intelligence I am
totally in it to winning I am 100%
oh man you get out of here yeah oh okay
so you're gonna be a little [ __ ] and
throw your sword axe there
get out of the way get your bloody blood
out of the way I need that no no no no
no no no no no no no whoa whoa get out
here get out here with that good I
didn't need my son it was weighing me
down
good I didn't need those balls they were
weighing me down good I didn't need my
life
maybe if I al not happy I'm not a happy
man
I use the key get out of my way
open the gate get dead
this is how this is how mass murders are
created you know that's right this is
not mass murderers happen you think
they're in the future when I'm at my
insanity hearing they'll use this as
evidence to know that I actually did
lose my mind like long ago long ago okay
if that would have killed me I would
have been you like go do son of a [ __ ]
and I will take this with me into
victory
suck on this [ __ ] suck on that - oh
this hey hey hey what is with these
particular characters that the sword -
move over
what is with you
I spilled my drink not doing well not
doing well everybody I'm not doing well
I'm not doing good I can't say that I'm
doing good to get out there with this
[ __ ] it's in my chest you get it out
of there
cuz I know this with some douche Ness
it's gonna somehow blood is slippery and
I can't get up the stairs you throw it
you [ __ ] you throw it you throw it and
bring on your death will not be beaten
by you sorry sack of [ __ ] you are the
worst okay you're coming with me douche
you're coming with me yeah
I've gotten past you now you let me have
those chairs you [ __ ] you let me up
these stairs no not with your douchey
ways of dying you as though you loved me
what are you doing